Kurt Warner draws the the assignment of
being part of the NFL Network pregame
show merely because the Rams are playing
tonight and Kurt's on the show how are
you Kurt everybody how are you is that
an accurate description right
if the Rams were not fully not fully
accurate but but yeah that's part of it
hmm okay so I'm just trying so the Rams
aren't playing tonight
your your home right now come on let's
be honest Kurt right I'm doing a few
other Thursday night games this year not
not just the RAM okay that's what I'm
saying
Cardinals Cardinals you're doing the
Cardinals right you are the Iowa
Barnstormers on this Thursday okay cuz
we're then we're kind of out of your
team's unless we don't there's no I
don't think there's any Thursday night
games in Amsterdam also occurred no I'm
definitely not taking that trip okay the
Honda inside a report here with Kurt
Warner on the Rich Eisen show how you
you watch as much film as anybody I know
Kurt how good is the Rams offense what
in the world is McVeigh doing that
others might not be able to bottle in
the NFL these days well I mean I think
they're good for a lot of different
reasons I mean the first and foremost
the more balanced you can be as a team
the better you're always going to be and
I'm not sure there's a better offensive
line in football than what the Rams have
we all know about Todd Gurley and the
beast that he is and he's big and he's
strong and he's fast and he can run
outside and he can run downhill and you
know he's a monster to tackle every time
you have to tackle him
so you couple that with they've got the
best play action game in the league
because of it they do a great job of
making a lot of their past plays look
like run plays so you got to come down
here and attack because that guy's so
big if you just sit on your heels he's
gonna run you over so your attack they
got a great you know they got great
playmakers on on the other side where
you do that they can you know they can
they can get behind you with guys like
Brandon cooks and Robert woods and they
just have weapons all over the place and
then you know couple with that is Sean
McVeigh as you mentioned he's got a
great offensive mind
and you know I talked to him and Jared
Goff a little bit this week and both of
them brought up the point of how smart
their players are how smart their
skilled players are specifically
allowing them to do all of these crazy
things that John McVay comes up with and
so you get smart guys you have a great
scheme you have great talent and you
have the ability to change and adjust
and run complementary routes to to
everything that you do it makes it
extremely hard to stop and you know
Jared golfer in the passing game is very
confident they're protecting him very
well so he's got chances to read the
field there's just not a lot of
weaknesses on this defense I mean on
this offense and then you couple that
with like I said McKay's genius in the
intelligence of the players and every
week they're coming up with new things
and new twists on things that make it
hard to watch the scheme against and
Kirk Cousins has been throwing the ball
for the first two weeks of the season
very well I mean he's top five and yards
he's he's top five and inaccuracy is
well Curt and then last week I mean I
guess the the simple two word question
about last week's loss to the Bills is
what happened well I mean it's one of
those games where the ball starts
rolling against you early and that's
what happened is that you know turnovers
and big plays for the bills and
Minnesota found themselves down 17 to
nothing before you could blink yeah I
think the most disconcerting thing about
Minnesota is yes they've you know Kirk
has good numbers but they're down in
terms of big plays that they're making
as an offense I mean last year Case
Keenum
and that team was averaging
six-and-a-half big plays per game right
now after three games Kirk Cousins in
the group are averaging four and if
there was one thing that I thought you
made the change from Kirk from case to
Kirk it was believing that case was more
of a complementary piece and Kirk could
be more of that dynamic big play
game-changing right arm high guides and
that's what we haven't seen
from their offense and so it looks on
paper you know really strong but they're
just not making those big game changing
plays I mean last week it was hard for
me to believe that they were down 17 to
nothing early and they didn't score
until late in the game I mean they
didn't put any points on the board and
only got one touchdown in a game where
you're getting blown out I would have
expected with the group of pieces that
they have there that they would at least
have made a run at this thing even
though they were down early to be able
to push the Buffalo Bills and force them
to have to make some plays down the
stretch but they just never got on track
and it really had struggles getting the
ball in the end zone I know everybody
sees the tie against the Packers but if
you think back they have seven points
through three quarters in that game as
well before they exploded in the fourth
something's a little bit off offensively
and they're struggling to put points on
the board Kurt Warner here on the
insider report the Honda inside a report
check out Kurt every single Sunday
morning with me Irv and mooch 9:00 a.m.
Eastern Time on NFL gameday morning and
he's part of Vikings Rams on the NFL
Network pregame show tonight postgame as
well and you could catch it on Fox along
with the NFL Network tonight so I don't
know if you heard I'm assuming you might
have just come off a plane but the NFL
Troy Vincent the head of NFL football
operations said the competition
committee met via conference call last
night to talk about the roughing the
passer penalties in the way they have
been called and saying that they
reiterated their position on quarterback
protection and that there will be no
changes to the point of emphasis
approved this spring to the rule that
was in place in nights in 1995 however
they did clarify techniques that
constitute a foul put out a video that
al Revere on narrated showing four plays
of what's not permissible and four plays
of what is permissible and interesting
ly enough of the four plays that are
permissible the Clay Matthews hit on
Kirk Cousins two weeks ago was not one
of them what do you think Kurt Warner
well again it's a fine line because I
think so many of us that are former
players or that cover the league and you
know think
about long term we're all about safety
and you know nobody's ever gonna argue
that you know you don't try to continue
to do things that make the game shape we
all want that and specifically where the
head is involved in taking the head out
of the game I just think it gets you
know increasingly harder to play defense
in the league with a lot of the rules
that we have and then to watch you know
some of these roughing the passer
penalties that we have that I can't do
anything but look at it and say what a
great football play you know I mean I
can even slow it down and go okay what
was the guy supposed to do here how is
he supposed to avoid I mean the Clay
Matthews hit this past week against Alex
Smith to me was a great football play
did everything right
you know wrapped him up head was out of
the play but he fell on him and no
question he fell on him because he ran
through the guy because that's the way
it was set up on the play and then have
a flag come out in that situation it
just makes you shake your head and yeah
I just because I just don't know what is
supposed to be done in those situations
and you don't want to take football out
of football you don't want to take a
great football play out of the game
I understand anything excessive I
understand picking a guy up and driving
him to the turf and those sorts of
things being flagged because there's
that never any part in our game for you
know things that go outside the lines
that aren't done maliciously but good
heart football plays should be rewarded
not penalized and I just feel unless I'm
seeing something a little bit off and
I'll have to watch that video that a lot
of these plays are just good football
plays that couldn't be avoided if they
tried and we got to do a better job of
not penalizing people for playing the
game hard fast and strong and trying to
do it the right way well I should say we
were just showing the video that al
River on in the head of the football
operations tweeted out while you were
saying that and I should also mention
that the four impermissible plays also
did not include the Clay Matthews hits
either one of them so maybe
and river on did use the phrase a couple
of times in narrating it when I listened
to it off the air Kurt the words the
player when they showed that was a flag
of all offense did not have any attempt
to brace himself which Clay Matthews did
attempt to do with his left hand when he
did take down cousin cousins maybe
that's the out here maybe that's it yeah
i don't know i haven't played defense in
a long time and you know i know the game
is fast and it's amazing to me what
Claire's are able to sink in the moment
you know what they are able to see in
the course of a second or half a second
I just feel like that's you know that's
a very difficult thing to do as you're
you know trying to get past somebody and
get to the quarterback and see where
he's at and he's moving and then you hit
him and then to think okay now take your
hands off and try to brace yourself I
just feel like that's a lot to think
about it and not that our amazing
players can't do it I just think if
that's the caveat it's gonna be very
difficult for these defensive guys to be
able to think about that every single
time in the moment to avoid a penalty
Kurt Warner here in the Honda insider
report asked him the poll question Chris
especially since knowing Kurt as well as
I do and working with Kurt as long as I
have he loves questions when you ask
about an expectation level of player and
whether he will somebody succeed he
loves predicting so please ask him the
question Chris hey Kurt how's it going
man which of these rookie quarterbacks
starting this week Josh Allen Sam
Darnell Baker Mayfield Josh Rosen which
of these guys finishes the year with the
most wins the most win did you hear that
because it's all about the quarterback
right it's all about how the guys play
yes come on yeah I am going to say you
know what I'm gonna say Baker Mayfield
I'm gonna say that he finishes the
season with the most wins as a starter
well I guess we can't we
count last week because he didn't get
that win right Riyadh no that was uh
that went to tie rod I'm did indeed I
think they have a good team I think they
have good players around him I loved
what I saw when he came in last Thursday
playing confidently you know right there
to I think will be the Jets I think they
have some good pieces and I like Sam
Darnell I'm not sure they have as many
as Cleveland so I'm gonna say the Browns
of Baker Mayfield okay good job Curt did
you feel do you feel less of yourself
than making that prediction or a little
bit yeah I do but for you guys I'll make
depredation what do you think happens
tonight what's your best guess about
this evening sir well again I mean I
think right now the Rams are playing as
well as anybody there at home you know
how tough it is to travel on the road
you know I know they're missing the two
corners which should make it interesting
but I just think they're the better team
we're playing better right now top to
bottom and anybody in the league and of
course Minnesota so I think the Rams
come out of this one with a win alright
Curt I look forward to seeing you
tonight I'm coming bye I'll see you then
all right buddy you the man that's Kurt
Warner the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience